the terraform stage helps you monitor  your configuration how exactly does the  state work how can I help you reconcile  manual errors learn more about it in the  short  the primary purpose of the terraform  stage is to store the bindings between  the objects in your infrastructure and  the resources declared in your  configuration  for example let's say person a deploys  VM using terraform  a person B accidentally deletes the VM  label through the UI  person a who's running terraform can use  the terraform state to reconcile the  environment to the desired State as  described in the configuration  are you ready to learn more click on the  three dots and then click on the link in  the description box to enroll in the  getting started with terraform from  Google Cloud course see you there